turn on your cam Xand order some nachos
because today we're looking at the
longest episode of black mirror yet
now I've scoured the internet examining
some of the different theories involving
this film because let's face it the
ending leaves a lot of unanswered
questions but none of them have
mentioned this huge detail
none of the dates make any sense the
timeline of this film is completely off
what do I mean by that we'll put on your
tinfoil hats ladies and gentlemen it's
time to look at some examples when Alice
aka Lola underscore Lola goes to meet
barnacle Bob at his hotel she checks the
calendar and her phone where we can
clearly see the current date Saturday
September 13th 2014
but this doesn't match up with her other
calendar we saw her marking off earlier
in the movie which shows September 13th
as a Wednesday not to mention her
brother's birthday is shown here on
Saturday but earlier on it was on the
Friday now you're probably thinking
maybe that's just an error on the
filmmaker or the art department and I
would be inclined to believe you if this
didn't happen about a dozen more times
in this movie let's take a look yeah
yeah pull it up when Alice first
arranges her meeting with barnacle Bob
she says hey I hear you'll be in my neck
of the woods next week but next week
doesn't line up with any of the dates
she puts in her calendar also if her
definition of my neck of the woods is
253 miles away that's just a bit odd
even odder is the address 666 Bradley
Boulevard Barney here is really the most
interesting character when it comes to
deciphering this ending he and Tinker
boy are the only ones who have some
connection to the other girls who have
been copied
but it's only Barney who has met the
other girls in real life that we know of
when Alice and Barney go on their
Mexican lunch date he discloses two
important details one that he won a date
raffle with Sarah bear and blossom only
blossom showed up and wydad only blossom
show up because he's been talking to a
copy of Sarah bear Sarah didn't call or
anything she forgot or else how would
she also show up with baby girl after
baby girls actual death so we can
confirm that when Alice does her
investigation that baby girl winter
angel Helena Boy and Lola are all copies
where are the originals now this is
where I'm going to
posit an insane theory one which I call
the algorithm theory what we're watching
isn't real we're watching an algorithm
one that is evolving and becoming
smarter eventually taking over its
previous version all the copies that are
of women who have died making them good
candidates to be copied since there's no
original tinker boy himself even says he
knows who will make a good candidate to
be copied
that's because good candidates are the
ones who have died but to fully
understand this theory we must examine
baby girl
aka Hannah Darren because we have actual
proof that she died when Alice first
investigates her we see this a memorial
webpage showing her year of birth and
death 1989 to 2014
but as she swipes down on the same exact
page we see her day of passing being
July 17 2015 if we're currently in 2014
how did Hannah die in the future when
Alice investigates further at the
internet cafe we see this article which
shows a completely different date of
birth October of 1991 not 1989 and that
the article was written six months ago
if Hannah did indeed die in July of 2015
like the other web page said that would
make the current date roughly January of
2016 but I thought we were in 2014 and
the discrepancies get even more
confusing the copyright on the cam
website says 2004 to 2017 but Sarah bear
shows us being online and that her last
broadcast was November of 2014 if you
want to get even more insane is the fact
that video game Alice picks up for her
brother's birthday is the division which
didn't even come out until 2016 can you
see how all these little things are
starting to add up it's not just one
mistake here there it's literally dozens
but let's dig deeper in the beginning
Alice talks about how she just moved in
and that's why there are boxes
everywhere yet throughout the whole
course of the movie the boxes never
moved they're never unpacked the only
thing she opens is her boxes from her
fans there's also the significance of
her name's Lola and Alice both of which
have significance Lola is the short-form
of the Spanish derived Dolores which
translates as Sorrows and Alice does
indeed go through her own sorrows over
the course of this film Dolores was also
one of the titles given to the Virgin
Mary and funny enough when Tinker boy is
caught having his
happy time in the washroom what does he
say forgive me mother Mary the name
Alice is also indicative of Alice in
Wonderland the tale of a young girl lost
in a land where logic is thrown out the
window we are essentially watching Alice
in her own Wonderland one of the
algorithm even her clothing doesn't make
any sense
theory the scene right before she
confronts Tinker boy she's wearing her
blue bird sweater then somehow has
changed into this and then when she
wakes up she's back in her blue bird
sweater again now it's possible she
changed and then changed again into the
things she was wearing before but I just
find us odd the algorithm Theory relies
on what Tinker boy said about the
algorithm itself it takes every last
detail about a person it can find online
- best recreate how that person would
act and that could explain all these
discrepancies these are all the little
bits of info the algorithm has taken and
is now trying to put together logically
tinker boy even says that this is just
all a test and he's there to help her
her algorithm is being tested eventually
taking on the previous version in the
final confrontation with Lola but one of
the more gruesomely poetic things I
found about this ending is what it says
about vanity in fact the way Alice
overcomes the previous algorithm is by
destroying her vanity aka breaking her
nose on her actual vanity how's that for
irony so what do you guys think of this
theory I'm sure there's a ton of holes
you can poke in it but I like this
interpretation better than what I've
seen in a lot of other explanations as
always on this channel I'm trying to dig
deeper and give you guys different
perspectives so give it a like share it
and subscribe with the Belon because I
have more videos coming your way and
remember daddy loves you very much
[Music]